If you're a Udacity student you can earn karma points by posting questions in the
forums or answering others questions. If someone likes your question or your
answer you can earn 15 karma points. If the person who asked a question accepts
your answer you can earn 25 karma points. And if you accept some of the answer
you can earn 5 points. However, you can also lose karma points by being
downloaded by having a flagged post or if your flagged post is deleted. Most of
these students are pretty awesome, see they are all in the positives and if you
have a certain number of karma points you can even edit other people's posts or
delete others posts. The karma point system is explained in the Udacity FAQ section. I
put the link at the bottom. Well, I put together a data set for you guys to
analyze, which is the average number of Karma points per post. This data set has
200 students. Click the link I shared to access this data.